con sus canales vacíos y las góndolas
turísticas inutilizadas venecia es casi
irreconocible
un año y medio después del inicio de la
pandemia la ciudad está replanteando su
modelo de desarrollo con un objetivo
evitar los excesos del turismo de masas
queremos evitar los tumultos para eso
queremos tratar de programar los accesos
a la ciudad pensamos que la solución sea
a través de un sistema de reservas quién
quiere venir a visitar venecia podrá
venir pero reservando antes para poder
reservar la alcaldía prevé el pago de un
tiquete de entrada a la ciudad a partir
del próximo año y un mayor control del
flujo turístico en esta sala convergen
las imágenes de más de 500 cámaras de
seguridad repartidas en la ciudad fui
con freeze constructiva tanque de l
altre aquí llegan los datos de todas las
centrales operativas tenemos modelos que
nos ayudan a afrontar la llegada de
turistas a la ciudad en momentos de gran
afluencia de ingresos se dio cita el
ticket te costará tres euros en los días
de menos afluencia turística en la
ciudad la medida general intensas
polémicas es una chica ninguna ciudad
puede encerrarse y pedir un tiquete de
entradas en un museo no somos un museo
en un parque de atracciones solo chicos
en venecia
en venecia es necesario limitar la
cantidad de turistas que vienen solo por
un día sin aportar nada a la ciudad
estoy de acuerdo porque hay que proteger
el patrimonio de venecia recibe cada año
28 millones de turistas algunos de los
cuales llegan en cruceros
hasta hace pocas semanas estos barcos
pasaban delante de la plaza de san
marcos en pleno centro algo que el
gobierno italiano prohibió siguiendo las
recomendaciones de la unesco para evitar
que sea incluida en la lista del
patrimonio en peligro